hey this is pressure Locker in front of
you are three boxes one box contains
only apples another box contains only
oranges and the last contains both
apples and oranges the first box has the
label apples the second has the label
oranges and the third has label apples
and oranges but unfortunately all of the
labels are wrong and you have to fix
them so each box has the correct label
you cannot see inside the boxes but you
can ask for a sample from any box you
point to a box and you get a random
fruit from that box what is the minimum
number of samples you need to label all
of the boxes correctly answer wisely
because this has been asked as a job
interview question can you figure it out
give this prom a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
many people think you need several
samples to label all of the boxes
correctly after all if you get an Apple
it could have come from the box with
only apples or it could have come from
the box with both apples and oranges but
in this problem you know all of the
boxes are labeled incorrectly this
allows you to solve the problem using
just one sample the key is that you
should ask for sample from the box
labeled apples and oranges suppose you
get an apple now the box could contain
both apples and oranges or it could
contain only apples the key is that you
know the label of apples and oranges is
wrong
therefore this box must contain only
apples you can put the correct label on
this box now we can label the rest of
the boxes correctly we should next
consider the box that's label oranges
this box could have only oranges or it
could have both apples and oranges we've
already used the label for apples
so that label cannot be used so which of
these two remaining labels could the Box
be since the label of oranges is wrong
that leaves us the only choice that this
box should have the label of both apples
and oranges that means the final box can
only have one possible label which is
that it contains only oranges so just by
getting the one sample we could
correctly label all of the boxes now
I've gone through the case where you
would get an Apple from your sample what
would happen if instead you got an
orange well the logic would be similar
the box that's labeled apples and
oranges must have a wrong label
therefore the correct label would be
oranges you then consider the box that's
labeled apples you can reduce by process
of elimination that this must contain
both apples and oranges and the final
box must have the final label so you can
figure out all of the labels just by
taking a sample from the correct box so
there's another way to understand the
solution it's to consider the different
ways to label the three boxes notice the
first box can have one of three labels
for each of those labels there are two
possible labels that are remaining for
the second box the final box must have
the last label that you didn't use so in
this manner we can go through and
enumerate all the different ways to
label the three boxes as there are three
choices for the first label two
remaining choices for the second box and
only one label remaining for the third
box there are 3 times 2 times 1 or 3
factorial which equals 6 possible ways
to label the boxes there are 6
permutations now we need to exclude any
of the enumerations in which the label
matches the label on the box
we know that the box has an incorrect
label so for example the label of apples
has to be wrong so we know that these
first two rows could not be the correct
labeling similarly we go through the
other rows in which the other labels
would match what's written on the box so
we can eliminate any row in which one of
the labels matches the label that's
written on the box so we can eliminate
the first and second rows we can then
eliminate the third row and we can
eliminate the final row this leaves two
ways in which all of the labels are
wrong a permutation in which all of the
elements are
the wrong spot is known as a derangement
there are two possible derangement s--
now how do we identify which of the two
cases were in what we do is we ask for a
sample from the box that's labeled
apples and oranges
we know that the box that's labeled
apples and oranges has to contain only
one fruit once we figure out what that
fruit is we can identify which of these
two cases were in and we could label all
of the boxes correctly did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch from my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch on social
media app rush to Walker and if you like
this video please check out my books
there are links in the video description